bonsoir c'est fait les députés ont
adopté en première lecture par 360 voix
contre 117 l'ensemble du projet de loi
qui porte abolition de la peine de mort
un seul article additionnel est venue
modifier le projet initial mais cet
article engage le gouvernement a
effectué la réforme du code pénal pour
adapter et l'exécution des peines alors
sur le premier vote qui concerne
l'article 1 qui stipule la peine de mort
est abolie tout simplement il y a eu
exactement
369 loi pour l'abolition 113 contre très
peu de différences ou le voyez avec le
résultat sur l'ensemble du projet alors
tout de suite l'analyse de ce scrutin
daniel brême 42 membres de l'opposition
ont ajouté leurs voix à celles des
socialistes et des communistes
parmi eux jacques chirac rpr et michel
d'ornano udf je barre a voté contre côté
socialiste un sel votre style et une
abstention le garde des sceaux avait dû
ferrailler une bonne partie de l'après
midi pour obtenir court qu'un additif ne
soit apportée à cette décision il avait
promis à ceux qui dans les deux camps
souhaitait obtenir des assurances pour
que les criminels ne soient pas venus
pour rapidement en liberté dès avril le
parlement serait saisie des textes sur
l'exécution des peines et le plus vite
possible ou plutôt dans un an que
l'échelle de ses peines serait révisée
un certain nombre de députés rpr et udf
ont refusé leur suffrage lors du vote
sur l'ensemble des six articles motif le
texte gouvernemental ne prenait pas en
compte leurs préoccupations
ils n'ont été qu'une dizaine et maître
badinter dit sa satisfaction
essentiel crève finir c'est une majorité
qui a dépassé la majorité
c'est important significatif que sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire l'article 1er
on ait eu une majorité si large si
larges pattes 25% de l'opposition
actuelle
réunis autour de l'abolition
c'est un moment dans l'histoire
oui le débat va maintenant rebondir au
sénat où le projet de loi sera présenté
les 28 et 29 septembre prochains un
autre réquisitoire en perspective pour
robert badinter car la haute assemblée
est loin d'être acquise d'avancé à
l'abolition mais le dernier mot restera
cependant à la majorité est
abolitionniste de l'assemblée nationale